[Musica]
Zoe Arienzo biazzo e nomi di mia figlia
è nata 40 giorni fa e al suo primo
respiro al suo primo grido è stato per
me il mio compagno le emozioni più
grande della nostra vita
aria è vita
Ma è proprio la stessa aria che
muovendosi produce dei suoni e in questo
viaggio che faremo insieme nei prossimi
12 minuti scopriremo come questi suoni
sono importanti per il nostro benessere
per la nostra vita
Quante quante volte vi è capitato di
andare dal medico e vi ha messo quello
studio scopo ghiacciato sulla vostra
schiena e vi ha chiesto per favore
faccia tre respiri profondi
Cosa sta ascoltando
il medico sta cercando di capire cosa
sta succedendo All'interno dei vostri
polmoni e Cosa succede quando abbiamo
una malattia respiratoria
facciamoci aiutare dai suoni alzate le
mani Chi di voi ha mai suonato il flauto
dolce a scuola
Ok tutti non so se vi è mai capitato ma
cosa succede se inseriamo del cotone
all'interno del flauto a volte gli
amichetti come scherzetto mettevano
questo cotone e faceva dei suoni molto
strani ve lo faccio ascoltare
sono
ora immaginate il nostro corpo quindi la
trachea il setto nasale come un insieme
di flauti e per qualche motivo questi
frodi si restringessero facendo dei
suoni molto fastidiosi come questo
[Musica]
Questa è l'asma
alzate prima di Quanti di voi hanno
l'asma o conoscono qualcuno con l'asma
anche qui una grande platea non siete
soli perché più di 300 milioni al mondo
hanno l'asma e tantissimi ancora non lo
sanno perché uno delle malattie più
sotto diagnosticate e che Cos'è l'asma
bene nella Sma questi tubicini che
entrano nel nostro polmoni I bronchi per
qualche motivo si infiammano può essere
per cause croniche o allergia per
esempio inquinamento da stress e
restringono quindi il loro nome facendo
passare meno aria e meno suoni
e bene la difficoltà Diciamo in questa
patologia è che è una malattia cronica
non costante a grandi fasi intercritiche
quindi periodi di benessere fantastico e
poi periodi purtroppo di aumento di
sintomi che causano attacchi di asma
e purtroppo l'80% delle persone con asma
hanno attualmente un'asma non totalmente
controllata questo che vuol dire che
spesso Magari stanno in una fase di
benessere pensano a sconfitto l'asma
Purtroppo la meccanica quindi non si
sconfigge mai E a questo punto A un
certo punto aumentano i sintomi e però
la persona Magari pensa Ah no o
l'affanno Sarà perché sono poco allenato
o magari per il fumo prenderò
l'ascensore e così via fino ad aumentare
questi sintomi che purtroppo a volte
sfogano in un attacco di asma e due
terzi delle morti provenienti da questi
attacchi d'asma potrebbero essere
prevenute Inoltre questi causano più di
28.8 miliardi di extracosti a tutta
l'Unione Europea Quindi è una grande
malattia con dei grandi impatti sia a
livello di vita di qualità di vita e di
vite che a livello di costi Servirebbe
uno strumento che può in qualche modo
misurerà ma anzi prevenire quando viene
in attacco in modo che possiamo curarlo
salvare vite e salvare i costi
Ma come viene attualmente misurata
l'asma ci sono due strumenti Uno è il
classico misuratore di Picco di flusso è
uno strumento che si soffia ogni giorno
mattina e sera e ti dice come sta
migliorando l'asma ma immaginate una
persona con una malattia cronica che non
solo c'è una malattia Deve portarsi i
narratori e tutto ma deve anche
misurarsi con questo strumento
Ovviamente ha un'aderenza molto bassa
oppure andando a visita Una volta
all'anno il medico fa la spirometria che
comunque una fotografia dell'asma in
quel momento in fase di benessere la
spemetria è piatta e inoltre non può
dirci nulla sul futuro A meno che non
facessimo la spinometria tutti i giorni
e che appunto sarebbe una soluzione
Insomma poco scalabile ma se vi dicessi
che c'è uno strumento disponibile che
potrebbe aiutare a prevenire per esempio
attacchi di asma ad individuarci come
sta sta evolvendo la nostra malattia
vi do tre indizi per indovinare questo
strumento
Il primo è uno strumento in grado di
collezionare Milioni miliardi di suoni
Il secondo è uno strumento facile da
usare pensatelosa dal bambino
all'anziano
il terzo ce l'hanno più di 6.5 miliardi
di persone al mondo anzi ce l'avete
probabilmente tutti voi nelle vostre
tasche ovviamente lo smartphone lo
smartphone oltre ad essere accessibili
da tutti in qualunque gioco del mondo ha
una sensibilità ai suoni molto più forti
di quella che è l'orecchio umano quindi
riuscendo a percepire anche delle
leggere differenze e come si fa però da
un respiro adesso a monitorare una
malattia Insomma c'è una grande
differenza Ebbene qua interviene la
scienza dei biomarcatori vocali
Praticamente dalla registrazione quindi
un respiro una tosse vengono passati in
questi modelli di intelligenza
artificiale che analizzano le feature
vocali e poi controllano ogni singolo
piccolo cambiamento che viene chiamato
bio marcatori vocale per restituire Un
output al paziente Ma sì ma comunque
come fa dal respiro semplicemente a
capire come sta andando l'asma pensate a
due grandi potenzialità di questi
strumenti
La prima è che possono essere allenati
con Milioni miliardi anche di più di
dati quindi conoscono il problema
biologico molto bene
e la seconda Ancora più interessante è
che essendo questo strumento collegato
con il telefono potenzialmente la
persona può registrare il suo respiro
Insomma una volta al giorno quando vuole
e anche diciamo questo strumento si può
risolvere il paradigma della medicina
personalizzata della medicina di
precisione perché anche cambiando
l'utente nella sua vita il modello si
adatta
Ma non è tutto rose e fiori perché
questi strumenti che magari li vedrete
nei prossimi anni in forma di semplice
app non sono delle semplici app sono
dispositivi medici software e perciò ci
sono tantissimi barriere per riuscire a
farli usare giustamente Insomma dalle
persone le tre barriere principali sono
la prima degli studi clinici Quindi c'è
un comitato etico che approva uno studio
clinico un pizzico di investigatore Ok
fantastico Cosa si fa si raccolgono i
dati questi milioni di dati per poter
allenare il modello e per poterlo
validare fantastico funziona questo
strumento geniale che riesce a predire
gli attacchi d'asma lo metto sul mercato
Eh no qua Se fai la seconda
regolamentazione ovvero essendo un
dispositivo medico l'Unione Europea
ovviamente Vuole essere sicura che i
benefici sono maggiori dei rischi e
quindi si entra in un secondo processo
con un comitato con un ente notificatore
che controlla i documenti in cui si
dimostra questa cosa stessa cosa poi lo
penso Ok perfetto ho fatto questa cosa
vai lo metto sul telefono no c'è anche
un terzo punto Chi paga Quindi
ovviamente nel sistema sanitario e
bisogna dimostrare che se lo Stato vuole
coprire Questo prodotto i costi siano
diciamo minori dei dei Risparmi che
sotterebbero utilizzandolo pensate che
in Germania da due anni e adesso si è
estesa anche in Francia anche in Belgio
il primo oggi possono prescrivere queste
app quindi lo Stato Ha fatto una lista
di tutte le app che vuole prescrivere
ovviamente in Italia ci arriveremo
Chissà tra cinque dieci anni ma siamo in
quel processo
Ebbene Adesso voglio concludere con un
esempio concreto Ok ma come funziona
diciamo questo strumento come potrebbe
funzionare e vi voglio mostrare il
nostro prodotto che abbiamo costruito
sull'asma è un'app per l'asma da una
parte è una compagna diciamo delle
persone con asma no quindi è tutto
quello che la persona con asma vuole
avere esercizi sfide Anche con che mi
fication esercizi di respirazione diari
dei sintomi reminder sulle malattie e ad
esempio sul Medio e su come cambia su
come comportarsi quindi aiuta alla
gestione della malattia e dall'altra
proprio sullo stesso strumento può
essere trovato questi test di
biomarcatori vocale ad esempio l'asma
Evolution test come funziona è molto
semplice la persona Clicca fa tre
respiri profondi
e ottiene il risultato Ma di cosa non
solo di com'è la fotografia dell'asma in
quel momento ma anche Quale è stato il
Trend nell'ultimo mese e con questo si
riesce ad identificare la previsione di
come evolverà la malattia nei prossimi
sette giorni immaginate di avere una
previsione medio sulla vostra salute a
portata di click quanto Questo potrebbe
influenzare le vostre scelte sulla
vostra gestione del vostro benessere
bene Adesso chiudete gli occhi siamo nel
2050 in qualunque mondo in qualunque
luogo mondo anche in qualsiasi ora e
fate tre respiri profondi questa volta
davanti al vostro telefono
Questo è il nostro futuro
ascoltiamoci grazie
[Applauso]